question
we definitely
please sit down
foreign
we urgently need
humanitarian corridors that are truly
safe and effective
and
that are respected by all
to evacuate civilians and deliver much
needed assistance
to that end
i have proposed the establishment of a
humanitarian contact group
bringing together the russian federation
ukraine and the united nations
to look for opportunities for the
opening of safe corridors with local
cessation of hostilities
and to guarantee that they are actually
effective
simultaneously
we recognize that we face a crisis
within a crisis in mario paul
thousands of civilians are in dire need
of life-saving humanitarian assistance
and many of evacuation
the united nations is ready to fully
mobilize its human and logistical
resources to help save lives in mario
paul
my proposal is for a coordinated work of
the united nations the international
committee of the red cross
and ukraine and russian federation
forces
to enable the safe evacuation of those
civilians who want to live
both inside the azov style plan and in
the city
in any direction they choose and to
deliver humanitarian aid required